Lindsay you know I gotta ask you before
we go we uh there was such a lost spell
over the weekend with Aaron Carter and I
know you liked Hilary Duff's tribute and
her post on Instagram I mean you guys
all really came up together can you
speak a little bit on that kind of
unique Bond and you know the reaction
you have when you see news like that
especially as you know part of this
generation of these young Stars you know
my heart goes out to his family and may
He rest in peace and God bless him and
yeah just a lot of love there uh you
know Lindsay I I can't believe this but
next year marks the 25th anniversary of
The Parent Trap I have a brilliant
Beyond brilliant idea and the 20th
anniversary of Freaky Friday
I know we seem to be
told I mean you are aging
oh me too honestly 13th anniversary
can you believe it's crazy how do you
plan to honor those films and any chance
we can see reunite with Jamie Lee Curtis
I love Jamie and we would definitely
love to work together again and we have
spoken so we will see yeah he's very
down for a Freaky Friday sequel I gotta
be a grandma
and just watching Lindsay tried to be a
grandma
um uh makes me laugh you know I think
when you work with such incredible
people you always want to have a chance
to work with them again especially when
so much time has passed and and to share
those experiences and bring something
great back to life and a new for a new
audience to see and a different
generation I think it's just that's the
best don't start with me and those
clothes are going back first thing
tomorrow why Everyone likes them you
look great look like Stevie Nicks who's
he
[Music]
foreign